-Welcome back.
We are here with Gwen Stefani.
Now, Gwen,
in honor of your new single,
"Let Me Reintroduce Myself,"
I want to help you
reintroduce yourself by asking
a few get-to-know-you questions.
-And by a few, I mean 50.
-Perfect.
This is "50 Yes or Nos."
-Oh, my God.
-♪ "50 Yes or Nos" ♪
♪ "50 Yes or Nos" ♪
Alright, like I said, there are
50 of these,
so you need to answer
as quickly as possible,
but say whatever you like,
alright?
Ready?
-Okay, okay.
-Here we go.
♪♪
-Did you grow up in Anaheim?
-Yes.
-Ever been to Disneyland?
-Is Space Mountain
the best ride?
-No.
-Have you ever seen a UFO?
-What was your first job?
Was it at Dairy Queen?
-Yes.
-Did you give your friends
free Blizzards?
-I would make myself mistakes
and eat them in the back.
-Did you ever do vocals
for Sublime?
-Yes.
-Were you the one who named your
ska band No Doubt?
-No.
-Can you do the ska dance
known as skanking?
-Yes, I can skank.
-Yeah, of course.
Will No Doubt
ever make more music?
-I don't know.
-Can we karaoke together
sometime?
-Yes.
-Are you afraid of the dark?
-No.
-Are you afraid of spiders?
-Kind of.
-Would you hold
a tarantula for $100?
-Yes.
-Is 5'8" tall?
-Do you believe in ghosts?
-Yes.
-Do you believe in
love at first sight?
-Yes.
-Do you believe in Bigfoot?
-Blake? Yes.
[ Both laugh ]
-Have you ever been skydiving?
-No.
-Does grass smell good?
-Yes.
-Have you ever seen your
fiancé, Blake Shelton,
dunk a basketball?
-Yes.
-Do you always eat breakfast?
-No.
-Are puppies cuter than kittens?
-I would go with yes.
-Is the Grand Canyon
really just a big ditch?
-I don't know.
-Yeah, if someone
has something in their teeth,
would you tell them?
-Yes.
-Are you a hollaback girl?
-No.
-Is bananas spelled
B-A-N-A-N-A-S?
-Yes.
-Is tomatoes spelled
T-O-M-A-T-T-O-S?
-No.
-Are tomatoes a fruit?
-Yes.
-Are you a vegetarian?
-Is there oat milk
in your fridge right now?
-No.
-Have you tried avocado milk?
-Did it feel amazing to get
the first win as a coach
on "The Voice"?
-Yes!
It felt so good to beat Blake!
-Does Carter Rubin
have the voice of an angel?
-Yes.
-Do you ever get dizzy when
"The Voice" chair spins around?
-No.
-Are cargo pants
making a comeback?
-I have no idea.
-Are mullets making a comeback?
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
And then, is it rude
to hang up on telemarketers?
-No.
-Are hot tubs gross?
-Yes.
-Yeah, they are.
Do you own a Ping-Pong table?
-No.
-Is cinnamon a good gum flavor?
-Do you remember those
Budweiser frogs?
-No. Oh, yes.
I think I do remember the frogs.
-During your
Las Vegas residency,
did you play any poker?
-No.
-Did you see Cirque du Solei?
-Yes.
-Do you like surprise parties?
-No. Not really.
-Do you make
New Year's resolutions?
-Not really.
-Do your remember when you
played Jean Harlow in
"The Aviator"?
-Yes. That was awesome.
-Is it acceptable to reply
to a text message
with just the letter "K"?
-Yes.
-[ Laughs ]
Should guac cost extra?
-No.
-Are you happy we're done?
-Yes.
[ Dinging ]
-We did it! 50 questions!
-That was hard.
All 50.
-That was a lot.
-My thanks to Gwen Stefani.
We love you, buddy.
Her new single,
"Let Me Reintroduce Myself,
is out now.